hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 9 the mid-season premiere rock
in the road and there's a lot to be
happy about with this episode Rick in
the gang having a new purpose some
intriguing mystery interesting
connections you might have missed and he
most effective way to clear a walker so
let's dig deep into this episode
starting with these opening images this
verse scene is a continuation of that
post-credit scene last episode with the
mysterious hooded figure in Boots
spying on Gabriel as he takes the night
shift on the wall and a lot of people
are wondering after proving himself to
be pretty loyal and useful over the past
season and a half why is Gabriel pulling
this big move of feeling all the town's
already sparse supply of food but if
Yuri watch this scene closely there
could be an answer first notice how
Gabriel seems calm at first reading it
Bible quietly patrolling the ground then
when he rounds the corner in the pantry
we hear this loud crash and Gabriel
suddenly looks panicked as he loots the
place so if Gabriel really were trying
to sneak off on his own this would be a
pretty dumb way to do it like I'm just
gonna duck ahead while everyone else is
sleeping and crash oh my god got all the
cancer areas so my guess is whoever was
watching Gabriel last episode has
infiltrated Alexandria then attack
Gabriel as he patrolled the pantry
forcing Gabriel to load up a car and
leave and many of you saw this but as
the car drives away you can see a second
figure set up in the car next to Gabriel
and I'm pretty sure that person is old
Bootsy now all it more on the theory
later but one other thing to point out
here it looks like negan drew Lucille
the bat on their food logs and this
gives us more context for why Olivia was
so terrified of negan like her job was
to run the pantry and everyday she had
to look at this grim reminder of what
would happen to her and her friends if
they don't provide then again if negan
really want to scare her he probably
should have drawn a picture of a gunshot
to the face okay moving on to the
hilltop with the current reigning Stamp
for most hated character Gregory
refusing to join Rick in the fight
against negan but notice when Gregory
sarcastically called hilltop fighters a
platoon of sorghum farmers there's a
painting of George Washington behind him
and this image of an American
Revolutionary War hero
brings back up something I talked
my breakdown of Episode seven the
parallels between this group plotting a
war against an oppressive regime that
squeezes colonies for resources and the
American revolutionaries plot in a war
for independence from Great Britain so
in the early days of the American
Revolution the thirteen colonies were
somewhat divided over whether to go to
war with the more radical rebels in
places like Boston while many southern
plantation owners didn't really want to
disturb status quo even though they
agreed rich taxes were unfair now
obviously this wasn't true for everyone
like obviously George Washington was a
Virginia farmer and bold military leader
who led the American armies against the
British pretty much the exact opposite
of Gregory also many other southerners
fought in militias composed of mere
platoons of farmers and it's find it
interesting how the american road to
independence lines up pretty closely to
the walking-dead road to war and there
are lots of other little parallels
including this line from Darrell who is
with us yang now to me that seems like
this shows version of Benjamin
Franklin's famous join or Die political
cartoon which began as propaganda for
the colonies uniting in the French and
Indian War but then later became a key
symbol in the war of independence
against Britain and even though
negotiations with Gregory don't really
go anywhere
some Hilltoppers do volunteer to be
cannon fodder for this militia and that
includes Verdi who you might remember as
one of the hilltoppers that Rick saved
in episode 11 of last season okay moving
on to the kingdom where Rick's shocked
reaction to Ezekiel Tiger Siva is taken
directly from the comic pleases me to
see you old friend oh right I forgot to
mention an entire and continuing this
parallel with the American Revolution
many early American ambassadors like
Benjamin Franklin Thomas Jefferson and
John Adams had to do a similar song and
dance to woo and eccentric King into
supporting their war effort and that
King was Louis the sixteenth of France
and sure
comparing the kingdom to France during
the American Revolution isn't perfect if
you look at history but both King
Ezekiel and King Louie had their pride
stung from previous defeat Ezekiel had
to settle for the secret truth of the
saviours and the French were defeated in
the Seven Years War and actually Louis
did collect exotic animals including a
tiger now I was interested in Morgan's
reaction here this is the first that
he's learned
the deaths of Glenn and Abraham and sure
Spencer Olivia too but still his
response is nonviolent if we can find
another way we have to maybe just about
negan just capturing him holding him and
that idea echoes Morgan's proposal back
in episode 12 of last season when he
tried to dissuade everyone from
attacking the satellite outpost we can't
leave them alive we live life is
possibility and really Morgan's idea to
capture negan as some kind of prisoner
of war refers back to the prison cell
that he built in that episode so this
has really been Morgan's objectives and
really episode four of last season when
Eastman showed him that Redemption was
possible through incarceration and
discipline and reflection and Morgan is
hoping that they'll try that with Megan
too unfortunately it sounds like Rick
and Daryl and the rest are like yeah no
thanks we're going to kill a bastard and
before I move on Rick brings up the
title this episode with its story rock
in a road about an ignored obstacle that
keeps causing harm to travelers until a
girl removed it and found a great reward
underneath and in case you were like
wait is the rock the tiger or Jerry it
pleases him indeed no the rock is
Meighan
the harmful obstacle that people just
assume they have to live with Rick is
the little girl in the story whose
family gets destroyed and she digs and
bleeds to remove it and the bag of gold
is the peace and prosperity that their
communities can have by removing Meighan
and that whole idea of digging
underneath the roadblock to score an
opportunity comes back again this
episode both literally and
metaphorically and I'll come back to it
but then we get this quick scene between
Carol and the kingdom Kate Benjamin and
notice how Carol offers him some
survival tips of how to be quieter when
he's walking around the woods
heel-toe heel-toe out here and it who
needs you want to keep quiet I heard you
from a mile away this reminded me of the
last time Carol instructed young people
back in season four with her creepy nice
lesson - Lizzie and mica in the prison
and based on how those students ended up
you can see why Carol is more hesitant
this time she doesn't really want any
more blood on her hands which is a shame
because and I may be reaching here but
Benjamin seems exactly the kind of minor
character that the show kinda wants us
to care about just because they
I intend on killing mom maybe as a
casualty whoo emotionally Drive Ezekiel
and Morgan into war in fact I think that
is likely the reason we get this
father-son moment between Ezekiel and
Benjamin where Benjamin says my dad
always said that if you're asked to be
the hero be a hero and I wouldn't be
surprised if those exact words echo in
Ezekiel's mind as he's cradling this
kids dead body at some point I shut up
in the hero and real quick notice how
the bedtime story that Ezekiel tells
been brother Henry thank God Almighty
yeah treated Lance is a feat by another
king dr. Martin Luther King Junior's I
have a dream speech free at last free at
map and I'll admit that's kind of a
weird bedtime story like it was a speech
designed to energize a crowd and inspire
the civil rights movement not puts them
to sleep that kids going to be up all
night freedom marching but really this
is interesting because just like how
Rick and his group were trying to follow
in the footsteps of American history so
is Ezekiel just a different part of that
history when dr. King advocated
nonviolent method just like Ezekiel ends
up doing Phil this proves that Rick in
Ezekiel do wants the same thing the
American dream of a safe place where
they can both coexist peacefully okay
moving on after Ezekiel refuses to give
Rick troops and Darrell stays behind
under his protection we hear [ __ ] in
over the radio talking about that surely
without fat Joey
Jenny Joey it's just showing so it's a
god damn trench yeah for real guys I
feel like skinny Joey's going to let
himself go also it's interesting that
negan brings up that Joey here because
if you remember back in episode 7
Savior's referred to fat Joey's
demolition expertise rigging the highway
with explosives to redirect the herd of
walkers away from all the communities so
by removing these explosives Rick is
risking letting the herd wander off
course and become a threat either to
himself and his allies or yet another
weapon that they can use against the
Savior's will see if or when that ends
up happening and notice how this whole
scene connects back to Rick's rock in
the road story first
Rick encounters a roadblock and rather
than going around it he clears it in
order to retrieve a reward these handy
explosives that they can use against the
Savior's and this brings me to probably
my favorite set piece this season Rick
and Michonne using the wire between the
Cars two clotheslines hundreds of
Walker's and according to AMC the two of
them broke a record for most on screen
Walker kills in one episode at over 300
though some of those might have been
from the explosion of the faulty
dynamite that Rosita left behind
and by the way Greg Nicotero shared some
storyboards that showed Rosita was
initially going to ignite that explosion
it looks like by throwing a baseball at
the tripwire and triggering the
explosive or maybe the baseball was like
a grenade that would be crazy
anyway this scene ends with Michonne
saying this line
now remember that was they call back to
her motivating line to Rick last episode
which if you didn't catch it then was a
version of a line of the comics we don't
die and that actually came from Andrea
who is still alive at this point in the
comics they kind of made Michonne fill
her role in the show and moving on back
to Alexandria let's talk about the word
boat being written in the notebook
now what's strange about this is Gabriel
would not know about Rick and Aaron
going to the boat this note had to be
written by whoever the person was in
Boots who was spying on them last
episode and that means this mystery
person wanted Rick who followed them
back to this place so just to recap Rick
and Aaron found this houseboat they
stole some guns off of it without any
ammo and a mystery figure watches them
and follows them back to Alexandria and
that person waits until nighttime and
then infiltrates Alexandria attacks
Gabriel forces them to take all the
town's food and weapons and then lures
Rick back to where Bootsie and her
friends can get the drop on them and
that brings us to our closing images now
a lot of people are wondering why Rick
is smiling here and that's because even
though he's surrounded by potential
hostiles this is a victory for him in
fact he might be looking at Gabriel in
the shot we'll find out next episode but
either way this is another rock in the
road paying off worms like everyone
assumed Gabriel had screwed them over
but Rick knew better this is just
another roadblock leading to a new
opportunity and in this case Gabriel's
mysterious disappearance with all their
supplies was a rock that led to a huge
well-equipped army of soldiers that Rick
can possibly recruit for his war effort
something that he was seeking all
episode and now found thanks to digging
under a rock in the road okay that
covers everything for this episode let's
look ahead to next week's episode titled
new best friends and I'm assuming that
title refers to this new group
potentially an army that can join Rick's
fight and convince Ezekiel to join the
fight as well and a sneak peak scene
shows us an overhead shot of this
group's home a landfill and if we're
continuing this American Revolution
parallel with each new community being a
different colony this trash colony would
obviously be New Jersey now this group
has made to look like a ton of people
some of whom are like freakishly tall
now I don't know how good of fighters
they are but if this war comes
the hoops team Rick definitely has the
edge and the promo for this episode
shows us this woman who looks like this
group leader we're on your lives you
want to buy them back and by the sound
of it this group looks at property
similarly to the way negan does but
something tells me they're going to be a
bit more reasonable and if you look
closely at this wide shot a few of these
garbage pail kids are covered up in a
very similar way to the person who is
fine on Gabriel and many of them have
very long hair just like that sided and
in case you comic readers are wondering
I'm pretty certain these people are not
the whispers I mean the whispers
obviously have a whole other thing that
makes them unique so this isn't them
this is an entirely new group to the
show not seeing the comics also next
episode looks like it will focus on
Daryl and Ezekiel at the kingdom and
tensions rise with the saviors and it
seems like Richard will try to use Daryl
as a more hawkish devil on the Kings
shoulder to counter Morgan's calls for
peace and isolationism and finally a few
lingering questions one do you like how
the show is expanding in this world so
quickly now I thought they were going to
stop with new colonies after Oceanside
but then BAM trash City New Jersey
personally so long as these new
communities are still interesting I'm
down to see more of them and - do you
feel like The Walking Dead is back on
tracks like let's be honest some of
those episodes in the first half of the
season definitely dragged a little bit
but now that Rick and his people have a
real purpose this show just works a lot
better when all these parties are
working together to solve their problems
hopefully the show can keep up this
momentum ok let me know what you think
in the comments and check out my
breakdowns from the first half of season
7 - and if you liked this video please
hit like and subscribe to new rockstars
and make sure you're getting email
notifications also please share this
video and if you really like us you can
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much to all of our current patrons
especially Kenny Smith you can hit me up
on twitter at EA box with any thoughts
you have about The Walking Dead or
follow new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos ok
thanks for watching bye